hello folks welcome to rational
science the only site on the internet
that does physics at all okay we have a
great day today uh I'm going to have to
skip the extinction segment got enough
on my plate as it is so uh I think I'm
going to dig in
directly um I'm going to be doing uh
what is it uh teleportation I'm going go
directly into another subject which uh
has become relevant and since we're be
beginning the year I think it's going to
help a lot just to get dig into this and
clarify it you know for the rest of the
year so to speak right okay and that's
uh ether what is The Ether a couple
people came over and had questions about
the ether and so we are going to address
that let's start there uh we have some
problems in um
in mainstream as well as the dissonance
you know the
dissonance and what is the problem well
they all have the same problem and the
problem is that they move Concepts
around they don't even realize it you
know and that's uh we call that
irrationality we call it uh being an
idiot meaning idiot being a big idea
okay we have a big idea these people
have big ideas they start moving
Concepts around and so um here's a uh
just a synthesis okay of what I'm going
to be talking about fatal problems with
both mainstream and dissidence okay what
Urus is called word salad they dismiss
it as semantics and we call it the
foundations of physics you must present
the foundations of physics you must
Define your words you must present the
objects and here you see some examples
is spacetime an entity or an event uh
you know you have the black hole you
have dark matter uh Dark Energy Big Bang
Singularity Etc you know uh are those
things or are they abstract concept is a
field mass energy are those things or
are they Concepts that's what we're
getting to you know that's that's the
issue and uh these people treat them as
things they reify all these Concepts
they are Concepts they reify them and
but the uh dissidents you know although
these dissidents they do the same thing
people like the electric universe and
ether and flat earthers all these um
people who object to the establishment
to the
mathematical uh establish mathematical
world out there that rules the waves
right and what do they move well they
move electricity plasma and ether and
the question is these uh words represent
objects or concepts okay that's the
issue Concepts we Define and things you
know we point to we have to point to
things when you present especially in
physics and what is an a thing an object
a
medium uh what other words can we have
stuff entity whatever uh it's that which
has shape okay that's what it is
uh all objects have
shape um there's not one that you can
even imagine that doesn't have shape but
if you do please let me know I want to
know if any object that doesn't have
shape it's a universal property of all
objects have that and uh Concepts we
Define we can't point to Concepts
because a concept is a relation between
two objects really okay so um and so we
move there and say whoa when I to focus
here see if I can get myself back
here
sometimes good sometime there he goes
Jesus more or less
hello uh I hope you can hear me fine
also okay and I'm still not in there
completely
H I don't know why I went out Focus
there we go okay got myself back um
anyways uh it's irrational to move a
concept it's irrational to say you're
going to move running or flying you know
you can't move what's already in motion
okay aside from the fact that it's not
an object it's not a thing what are you
seeing you know motion is two or more
locations of one object if you don't
have an object you're talking about a
concept then you know what's moving so
you need an object and for physics you
can't start without imagine there's
nothing in the universe you know what
you what are you watching what's
happening you know and so the first step
of the scientific method has uh or you
can say the first two steps one is to
present the objects you have to present
the object you have to point to it and
the second one is that you have uh to
have
definitions solid definitions for the
key words the ones that make or break
your theory and if you don't have those
two things you can't even start nobody
wants to listen to your theories because
they have to be garbage okay the only
way you can present a rational theory is
by beginning to make sure that you point
to the objects and that your definitions
are sound then you can start you know
explaining whatever you want to explain
then people can follow your
presentation okay so that's the starting
point we call it uh establishing the um
uh foundations of
physics Okay so what do we call these
people we call them idiots okay what is
an idiot an idiot is someone who
attempts to move
Concepts and we know most of the ones
that they move in mathematical physics
in the establishment you know black
holes dark matter all that stuff uh but
then the dissidents they usually work
with these words the ones that are in
the little rectangle there red rectangle
plasma electricity uh the flat earthers
love the word density uh ether lot of
the electric universes also move ether
or are ether ISS right and just about
everybody in uh mainstream and the
dissidence they all move the wave they
wave the waves and yeah an idiot is a
person with Big Ideas okay that's what
an idiot is and uh they are irrational
people because because they never Define
their terms and they dismiss all this
stuff as um they call it word salad word
Wizardry or semantics they say that's
not important I want to do physics well
if you want to do physics you absolutely
must have objects and solid definitions
so you can't elude that and here's just
a synthesis of the people in the
electric Universe okay the Thunder
bolters Thunderbolts are the gods and
what they propose are is electrics
electricity right and they start moving
the electricity even though it's already
moving according to them they don't know
what electricity is the the best
definition they have is that it's the um
movement of electrons from atom to atom
and of course by doing so what they're
actually invoking is the planetary model
okay so if the electron bead that is
orbiting the nucleus is moving from atom
to atom what they're invoking what
they're using uh essentially is the U
planetary model okay then they also also
proposed this nonsense called the fourth
state uh plasma I thought the fourth
state was Georgia and uh you know these
people say it's plasma I didn't even
know there was a state called plasma
anyways these are the words they use
they never Define them they don't
realize that plasma uh as it relates to
matter um is not a state see solid
liquid and gas you don't need to have
any motion so they are static
they are states whereas plasma is always
in motion it's ionizing it's in the
process it involves it invokes and it
includes embodies uh motion the word
plasma already embodies motion whereas
solids liquids and gases do not so you
have ionization constantly going on you
can't have a state known as plasma St
Plasma's not a
state and again Georgia is the the
fourth state so I don't know where they
got that plasma is the fourth state no
way okay so uh that's a starting point
just in general terms and one fellow
came over and he said the following he
says you want me to draw The Ether
that's what we said last time that
people should draw The Ether and he was
one of the ones who replied to this and
he says I can draw you some ether just
like you drew me your ropes okay I can
draw you some kind of medium out of my
mind just like you drew ropes good that
Obsession of yours is ridiculous what
will that serve I don't know what ether
looks like oh he's already confessing
any more than you know what your threads
look like okay let's find out it's all
supposed to be invisible and intangible
remember okay not being good at drawing
stuff okay so he's saying he's a poor
artist I guess doesn't mean that it
doesn't exist okay that's all very
childish Bill do you know what air looks
like
okay so uh he threw the glove in my face
so we're going to address that we're
going to find out um if he if any of his
arguments have any Merit you know so we
do have to start by with scientific
method which is essentially what the the
main point of today's lecture is about
uh concerning ether it's uh these people
are are not in tune with the scientific
method that's what it's all about and so
here let's present the scientific method
what is science rational explanations if
it's an irrational explanation it is not
a part of Science and uh we're not going
to go over what rational explanations is
we're just going to say for rational
that movement of Concepts is irrational
okay and so what does physics deal with
one of the two branches of science it
deals with objects and it tries to
explain causes and mechanisms that's
what we do here primarily okay and there
you see the on the right the rational
scientific method and it includes the
first step there that's the one we're
interested primarily today um known as
hypothesis also assumptions or
suppositions and you need to present the
objects and the definitions those two
are cinon you must do those okay
definitions form the what we call the
foundations of physics okay so you have
to have some key wordss uh object exist
location
distance motion those words have to be
defined because you're going to use them
to explain what do we explain causes and
mechanisms okay and then you move on to
the initial scene which is the first
scene the first frame or uh in the uh
Universal movie okay everything's static
there you just point to everything in
the in the um screen or or wherever
whatever props you're using and then you
move on to tell your theory okay so that
people can follow your presentation a uh
that's a logical way of presenting all
this you point and you say this is a
horse that's a buggy and I'm going to
explain how the buggy moves from A to B
and you put the horse in front you time
to the buggy and the horse moves and
takes a buggy with them that's an
explanation everybody can follow it
everybody can see it on the screen you
can fill in the you know the blanks
wherever needed you can explain what
they're observing and why the you can
explain why the cart moved from A to B
okay that sort of thing and that's the
way we want everything in science we
want to be able to explain things in
that way and uh we don't have that in
science and in fact nobody can explain
in quantum mechanics and in general
relativity and in strength Theory they
can explain why this falls to the floor
and that's the only experiment we ever
needed for Gravity we need to know what
causes what's the mechanism that mother
nature uses to make this pencil fall
downwards okay that's all we want to
know and the people are out there saying
well let me tell you it's warp space war
time and there's a hologram on the black
hole and what's that got to do I just
want to know why this falls to the floor
that's all why does it fall to the
ceiling that's all we want to know
understand well okay so what if we had
no objects you know what if we remove
all objects from the universe well then
you get something like this in the
Universal movie you would get
nothing in uh each one of the uh frames
of the film okay so uh yeah not much
happening there inside the film you're
not watching anything because there's
nothing there if you want something to
happen you must put objects you can't do
physics without objects that's the first
rule okay so you absolutely need an
object and these people have never
realized that that you need objects and
so they work with Concepts they say oh
the field oh energy you know uh and and
they don't realize that all these all
these thingies that they think are
thingies uh stuffs stuff right uh
they're all Concepts Field Mass energy
time it's all Concepts wave all those
are Concepts okay and uh so yeah if you
want to have something in there you have
to do it like this you have to oh let me
do this give me a second
here you have to have that you have to
have um objects in each frame of the
movie Okay so
on the left you'll see maybe the
universe the Stars whatever and the
somewhere in the sunent you see the rock
a tree and maybe a dog uh jumping on the
next frame so you have to put objects
then people can follow your presentation
they know what you're referring to when
you say rock or tree okay that's the way
it works in science if you're going to
explain a mechanism you had better had
objects you can't do mechanisms without
objects you can't do physical
interpretations without objects that's
the point the word physical that's uh
that's an object okay and uh so here we
see the difference between an object and
a concept again there's only two
categories of words every word in the
dictionary falls under one of these two
categories uh it's either an object or a
concept okay now you might say oh I know
of a third or a fourth or a fifth
category I don't care what category you
introduce I'm going to put them under
one of those two for sure it either has
shape or it
it's black or white yes or no on or off
okay either it has shape or it doesn't
that's who it is and that's a first rule
the the second one is that uh object is
that which has shape whereas concept you
know the definition of the word concept
is a relation between two uh objects
it's a word that invokes or embodies two
objects that's what a concept is so
you're establishing a relation a
comparison a contrast between two
objects that's what a concept is
okay so every word will fall under one
of those two categories either it's an
object or it's a concept there's no in
between no third category in the
dictionary okay and uh there you see
some of the
synonyms the first one is medium I'm
going to use that word medium because a
lot of these ethers they believe that
they use that word medium they think
ether is a medium and they don't realize
what they're saying is that ether is an
object a thing okay so medium is a
synonym of object medium is a CN of
thing okay so medium is what that which
has shape that's the definition of
medium we don't care if it vibrates we
don't care if it moves we don't care if
it's made out of
particles it has to have shape overall
so whatever you present for ether you
better be able to point to it and say
that that blob there that ball that Cube
whatever you point to that's got shape
and if it has shape now we can begin
your presentation you can't say well I
don't know really what it is and it's uh
something that's flowing and I don't
know where it ends I've never seen it my
I don't draw very good none of those
excuses will work you have to point and
name and say ether that's how that's how
we do it in science okay and uh yeah
there you see the synonyms for concept
okay we point to objects and we Define
Concepts you can't define an object you
can't Define the word table you point to
a table then you can describe it if you
want but for the ET for the Klingon to
understand what you're talking about he
has to understand your language you you
say table he says I don't know what
table is and you point and say that's
table and you point to a table you point
to a chair you point to a tree you point
to a rock then now he understands what
your what what the noun refers to what
that word refers to okay so the nouns
you point to that's the way it is and
the nouns of physics are not the same as
the nouns of ordinary speech motion is a
or orbit or nouns in ordinary speech in
physics they are verbs okay so you can't
point to motion you can't point to orbit
because those are verbs okay there's a
thing they they motion essentially
that's that's what they
embody okay uh so here we have let's go
with this
go piece by piece and he says the
following he says you want me to draw
ether yeah I do I can draw you some
ether just like you drew me your ropes
okay do it very simple huh I can draw
you some kind of medium out of my mind
just like you drew ropes okay and there
I drew my rope there you see the rope in
fact um uh I can do even better than
that a little better than that I can
show you a rope here it is this is a
rope two- strand rope okay it's a 12
around the other two strands or whatever
you want to call it strings R threads
okay so we have one uh wound around the
other okay so this is what I called a
rope and if you don't believe me you can
go to the hardware store and ask um you
know for a two strand rope and it'll
give you something similar to that okay
that's that's the way it is okay so you
shouldn't have any problems uh
understanding what a rope is okay but
apparently this guy I don't know if he's
taking English as a s language you know
ESL 101 maybe he doesn't know what a
rope is but there I'm illustrating it
for him so shouldn't have any problem
understanding what a rope is that's what
we're proposing is uh this uh entity
that mediates both gravity and light the
what we call the Grand unified theory or
Theory of Everything right okay and he
says that Obsession of yours is
ridiculous what will that serve well
will it'll serve two things first it'll
determine whether you understand the
fundamentals of physics okay whether you
took physics 101 in your life and the
second one is uh show us what uh you
know going through your mind when you
say ether I want to know what what you
are thinking about when you say ether so
I mean if if you say that you've never
seen ether you don't know what it looks
like then then we don't know what's
going through your mind you have to tell
us what your God looks like I don't care
if it's the real God we don't care about
that we want to know what your God is
because you're giving us an explanation
you're giving us a physical
interpretation you might say God created
the universe no problem that's the
theory we want to know what God is we
still don't know what God is what do you
mean by God and so you first bring God
and point to and say that's God okay now
we know what you're talking about now
you can do whatever you want with God
but to say you know God I don't know
what he looks like I've never seen him I
just believe in him that's no good
you're not in physics you have to
present the object so we know what you
are talking about we don't care what God
is in reality we want to know what's in
your mind same with the ether you got to
tell us this is The Ether okay so now
you point you said show the show us the
ether now you can move it you can
vibrate it you can do whatever you want
you can make it flow or or U what is it
make it fluid whatever uh you can do
whatever you want but the first step is
show us your ether you can't just begin
in the middle of your movie and say it's
moving what's moving we haven't seen it
yet we don't know what's moving okay so
this is the issue and this is the
problem with all ethers okay so here is
The Ether okay that's what the ether has
always been bunch of particles and those
particles vibrate that's what they
always s in the 19th century especially
okay that all those uh particles are
vibrating and they create these waves
which they call light and supposedly uh
there were two individuals Michaels son
and Morley that proved that there is no
such thing as The Ether and so all these
people are you know in a war against
Michaelson and Morty saying well that's
not what they really proved and blah
blah blah well we don't care about
Michael Mor Michaelson or Morley or you
anyone who talks about The Ether the
first the first step is to present The
Ether and these people never do that and
Michaels and Morty didn't do it either
none of them you know
uh all the way to uh frell in um uh
uh
Faraday Maxwell none of them ever knew
what the ether was they never pointed
and say this is The Ether now let me
tell you something about let me move it
or do whatever with ether now they just
began talking and say oh The Ether like
we all know what it is don't we no we
don't please show us and that's where
they all failed they all failed that
okay okay so um where do we move from
there well here we have uh the same
fellow and he goes with the second part
and he says I don't know what the E what
ether looks like well that's great so he
doesn't know what it looks
like uh any more than you know what your
threads look like what do you mean I
don't there's a thread and you got it
Illustrated there in fact I'll again do
you one better and show you a thread
this is a thread you know you never seen
a thread three my
floss uh but uh that's a thread that's
called a thread okay I don't know what's
so difficult about understanding what a
thread is I do know what a what a thread
looks like and that's what we're saying
is that what underlies you know all
matter in the universe it's a closed Lo
thread it looks like this more or less
like a rubber band okay so let me show
that again I guess okay it looks like
that that's what we're saying that if
you entangle every atom in the universe
and every rope that interconnects any
two atoms you eventually end up with
something like that there's a closed
Lube thread what part of that this well
doesn't understand I don't know again
maybe he's taking ESL 101 this this
should be straightforward kid of baby
stuff you know I'm not talking about
here rocket science or anything I'm just
I'm just telling him you know uh what it
is so
yeah the thread there you say you see a
picture of it so hopefully you know
everybody understands what I'm talking
about I'm talking about a thread what's
so difficult about that and yeah so I do
know what my thread looks like but you
haven't show do what your ether looks
like okay and he says it's all supposed
to be invisible and tangible remember
well there's no provision for
tangibility or invisibility in the word
object in the word thing in the word
thread right thread is that which has
shape there you see the shape that's
what a thread more or less looks like
okay so uh an object is that which has
shape not that which you can touch or uh
see okay so don't use invisibility or
intangibility don't bring it into the
question into the issue into the
discussion because it's got nothing to
do with it okay so this fell I don't
know he's he's still doesn't understand
what he's supposed to do here apparently
he's supposed to illustrate The Ether so
that we can see what he's going to
vibrate what he's going to flow make
flow or make fluid or whatever we need
to see it first then he can move you
know he can present a flying carpet for
all we care you know and then said now
it uh waves fine no problem we because
now we see the carpet but you can't say
The Ether and I don't know what the
ether is I've never seen it uh I cannot
imagine it but it flows and it vibrates
and it does all these good things no
that's not the way it works sorry
okay okay so he continues and he says uh
do you know what air looks
like well the first issue is the
question is not what is the shape of air
that's not the issue the issue is does
air have shape okay that's the question
you should ask it's a yes or no type of
question so that's the first thing he
did not understand so he thinks uh it's
a question of what is the shape of
energy what is the shape of uh Mass what
is the shape of of um a field or
whatever no the question is does energy
have shape does Mass have shape does
time have shape those are the questions
that he's got to answer and so when you
say ether we're not asking what is the
shape of ether what we're saying is does
it have shape and if it has shape you
should have no problem drawing it or
illustrating it you know sketching it we
don't need a perfect version of The
Ether we need something in front of our
eyes with contrast okay that's you know
contrast giving you a
contour okay uh and here's a since he
didn't know what um what air is here let
me show it to you
okay here we have an astronaut okay he's
taking a balloon and it's got air in it
in fact he can have any gas he wants in
it doesn't really matter so he goes out
there and he pops the balloon and out
comes the gas could be air could be
Xenon anything okay so we've got air
there we colorcoded it white so that you
know what we're talking about and the
question is does not what is but does
that white stove have shape okay that's
the question
and if it has shape it's an object it's
a thing okay in fact anything made out
of atoms had better be a thing had
better have shape okay and so yeah air
does have shape and he never figured
that out uh very simple things okay here
you have a a more realistic scenario
okay uh here you have the Earth on the
left hand side and we can't see the air
so we make it visible right in the
center and you see these different
layers of air okay and then we remove
the Earth from right the center and what
you end up is that this is 2D version so
you see rings but you're you're supposed
to look at that as if it were shells
different shells different
concentrations of air the closer you get
to Earth and less air as you go out to
the point where you see that black stuff
and that's uh no air over there so you
go from what someone raised the other
day which is we go from an area where
you have uh no vacuum to an area where
you have vacuum okay so it goes from no
vacuum to to vacuum and yeah you can
have no vacuum next to uh vacuum uh out
there in space in fact we do everywhere
around every Star between every Galaxy
you know there you have vacuum next to U
matter okay so yeah if you want to know
what air looks like there you have it
it's uh it looks like that more or less
okay there we Illustrated for you so
that you know what air looks like okay
air does have shape that's the point and
again it's not we don't need to draw it
perfectly just we get to convey the
notion that anything made out of atoms
such as a gas that's covering the Earth
had better have shape okay whether you
can see it or not has nothing to do with
it okay you're supposed to say well if
it's made out of atoms hopefully it um
you know it has shape and here's the
Flat Earth ver version of that I guess
that's how air looks like in the Flat
Earth Society I don't know
okay okay maybe maybe some someone from
the Flat Earth can clarify that for me
what air looks like according to
them capsules the Earth there you see it
okay here's the 3D version of air around
the earth more or less a picture that
you see there okay and um in fact here's
another one okay looks more or less like
that so use your imagination as much as
you can to visualize what air looks like
okay and uh here's a kindergarten one I
think uh I found out there you know
layers of Earth atmosphere so uh you see
the Earth and you see these different
layers of air or atmosphere whatever so
yeah all this gas uh does have shape it
looks like um if you had the eyes of God
it would look like shells around the
Earth Earth so uh should be no mystery
what air is what any gas is for that
matter okay so let's make sure we
understand all gases same thing they're
made out of atoms they had better have
shape what shape do they have inside a
balloon it has balloon shape what has it
what what shape does it have when the
um astronaut pops it out there in space
well some kind of blob but that blob
hopefully has shape all blobs have shape
okay there's no it's not a con an object
a thing okay so yeah liquids and gases
they all have shape they're all objects
they're all things and these people
never realize that they talk about the
word medium but they don't know what the
word medium means they think ether is a
medium but doesn't have shape yeah sure
tell me about it and then the last point
he made was that he's a lousy painter
okay I can't do much about that he says
not being good at drawing stuff well
that's no excuse we don't care about I
mean you know get someone else to ether
4 you are point to it somewhere on the
internet I mean The Ether has been
around for thousands of years right
since the days of the Greeks at least if
not earlier and so the question is uh
what picture do we have of ether out
there look him up and I've shown uh what
what it looks like it shows like a bunch
of particles that's what it is bunch of
particles that's what they always
illustrate for The Ether so that's what
the definition of this concept is bunch
of particles and he says that's all very
childish bill
yeah uh it's childish because you can't
do it because you're using excuses to
weasel out of the uh requirement and
again it's a requirement not of Bill
gaty it's a requirement of the
scientific method scientific method
absolutely requires that you present the
objects in physics and that you define
your terms we point to objects and we
Define
Concepts okay so uh let's go slowly
because these people are very far back
in uh their education physics education
here's um yeah we have hearts and we
have Love Is Love a physical object is
heart a concept and I think it's the
other way around heart is a thing and uh
love is a concept usually you know
that's the way we see it so here we have
a heart how do we present it well first
we present the one on the left which is
a static uh image of a heart and then we
move to the one on the right and show
how it moves so we can show maybe how a
heart pumps blood or whatever okay so
first you point to the static object
then you put it in motion okay very easy
straightforward or do we need any more
uh spend more time on that I thought you
know I think this is kindergarten stuff
but it is for me I don't know maybe
these people are struggling with all
this stuff okay so here uh we point to
love and and we point to Heart can we do
that well you can point to a heart and
say if you're going to use it say to say
that a heart moves mountains right you
can do that but you can't point to love
first of all because it's a concept all
you're pointing to is letters there and
you cannot say that love moves mountains
not in physics you can say a heart moves
mountains but not love okay and you can
put the the Heart In Motion okay here it
is and show it's pumping blood you you
can attach whatever you want to that but
you can show the heart expanding and
Contracting even though that's not the
real shape of a heart you say hey this
is what I'm going to use as a heart for
my presentation today okay and so you
have it pumping you want to explain how
blood is pumped by the heart but you
can't do that with love what are you
going to put for love we going to put
the letters moving is that what you're
going to do with this concept Called
Love okay so this is the issue the issue
is that uh these people you know they
they uh they want to move Concepts
around and again first you have to
determine what is a concept what is of
an object then if it's an object you
have to illustrate it so if you say that
ether is an object no problem we have no
problem with that but present the object
put it in front of us so that we can see
what object you're referring to and if
it's a concept then you have to Define
it okay because you can't point to a
concept and you can't put a concept in
motion so if you're going to use ether
as a physical object as a medium as you
call it hey then you got to illustrate
it it's an object you're treating as an
object not as a concept okay so words
are very important it's what all these
people call what they call it uh word
Wizardry or word salad or uh you know
semantics yeah they they skip this stuff
because they don't think it's important
and then they wonder why there are no
explanations for Gravity today yeah
there are no explanation for Gravity
because all these people are using
Concepts as physical object they're
moving Concepts around they talk about
energy mass and field and charge and
whatever and time you know and none of
them have anything to do with physics
okay none of those belong to physics
they're
absolutely um Concepts and they are
mathematical Concepts specifically
nothing to do with physics okay here
again we see a motor okay and uh maybe I
should put these the other way around
give me a second
here uh the one on the left is um the
one you have to present in a static mode
and then you put it in motion on the
right you explain a mechanism How uh
Machine Works how a motor works how an
engine works right so that's the way
it's done in physics first you point to
a static image of it and then you put it
in motion okay you can't begin by
putting it in motion from the start and
say uh The Ether is already flowing no
no don't make it flow yet the electron
never stops it's always moving around
the nut around the uh nucleus no no no
no please show it us the atom in a
static mode first then you can move the
electron the prot on whatever you want
to move first show us a picture of your
atom then you can do whatever you want
with it and uh and of course you know
they can't do that because as soon as
they present the planetary model you
know bore Rutherford model what are they
going to put they're going to put a uh a
ball in the center and little ball on
the side and they always draw this this
dotted line this circle around uh you
know around the atom and what does the
circle represent motion so they're
trying to embody motion into
picture that's not allowed in physics
you can't do that if if you're going to
present the atom this is what the
quantum atom looks like you know here
you have the proton here you have the
electron you can't show it in motion you
have to show it first like that one next
to each other and you say well that's
not true because you know the electron
always moving well we'll have God the
devil or whoever you know out there
who's a magician stop the Universe
freeze everything so that nothing moov
there's no Motion in the universe we
want to see a single frame of the
universal movie what do we see in there
we just see a ball and another ball
that's their model okay and of course if
that's their model they would have to
explain what prevents the electron from
flying away or falling into the positive
nucleus right okay another thing we have
to clarify is that uh we do not put
verbs in there okay and again uh what I
just said more or less here I'm
reinforcing that here you have monolisa
and uh people say well that's her smile
there you know I don't know if that's
her smile is she smiling or not well you
can't you can't synthesize smile in a
picture okay smile is a verb so there's
better be some motion when you talk
about smile you can't you can't um take
a snapshot of a smile because if you
take a snapshot or draw a picture or
whatever paint a picture uh and you put
her and you say that's monolisa smiling
well I don't know because I don't know
what frowning is I don't know what
straight face is you know what normal
face what her normal face is so I don't
know if she's smiling for that I would
have to have a comparison I have to see
a change in her face in other words I
would need something like this
okay here you see
it and you have to see Mona Lisa moving
then you can see her changing her face
or whatever then you say okay I see what
Mona Lisa is doing now she's smil
smiling frowning you know she's moving
her face now I can understand frowning I
can understand smiling and any of those
and what we do is if we stop it like
there you know uh then you can figure
out what uh frowning is but only if you
have a comparison you know you have the
normal face in the center you have
frowning on the left and smiling on the
right okay now you can talk about smile
and frowning or being angry or whatever
those are verbs you cannot synthesize a
verb in a picture because you're uh
assuming too much you're reading more
into what's in there than what's in
there you know uh what you're saying is
that you have already a memory of her
with her normal face and now you're
going to see her smiling okay because
you're already assuming too much it's
not in the picture you can't you can't
show the ET or the um clling on you
can't show him smiling in a picture as
far as he's concerned that's her only
face and if you want to see her smiling
well you have to see before and after
then you can see it and for that you
need two frames of the movie okay so you
cannot synthesize smiling in a single
picture
Okay okay so what do they H do it in how
do they these ether is proposed well
they show you something like this or
this what they describe because the they
can't do anything else and they show you
something like this or this is what they
have in the back of their mind or this
is what they're describing to you for
you to visualize because they never
illustrate it so they show something
like this okay they say That's The Ether
you say what am I staring at I mean what
is that well let me explain it to you no
no no no I don't want I don't want to
listen to your explanation uh I want to
see The Ether before you move it this
thing is already in motion and
apparently it's infinite because I don't
see the edges of it the only reason it
has edges here is because you know the
frame is around it but other than that
this thing continues uh forever you know
so when they say oh the The Ether I
don't know what it looks like well you
don't know what it looks like because
you're assuming or you're essentially
stating that it's infinite that uh it
has no end that extends forever even
Beyond SpaceTime you know it's forever
there's nothing around it okay so that's
what you're saying and that's the same
thing the um people that propose
SpaceTime are saying they're saying
SpaceTime well where does it end what
does SpaceTime look like
and they said well I don't know I've
never seen it it's a fourth dimension I
can't even imagine it well I mean again
they show you this tester and they say
that's a four dimensional Cube or
whatever well if that's what's on the
outside I want to know what's out what's
giving it shape how come uh this tesak
has shape or the hypersphere why does it
have shape what's on the outside and
they say it's an invalid question you
can't ask that question yeah because
they can't answer it that's why they
they want that answer that
question Okay so uh what do they see it
they see it as a fluid that's flowing
like a river and again I put the frame
there okay the Yellow Frame just so uh
you know that that River continues
forever and so this how they present it
I'm saying well you're you're too you
went too fast I I need I need to see it
stopped I I need to see all motion
stopped okay and so now we we see The
Ether without any motion if this is what
they're proposing right I'm trying to
put words in their because they're not
putting the images so I'm putting the
images here they can criticize any image
they want no problem but then they have
to put something to exchange they can't
just walk away and say well you got it
wrong Bill no no I know I got it wrong I
want to know what's right so don't tell
me I'm wrong tell me what's right okay
and so here's a static image of The
Ether of that same ether and the
question is does it extend forever okay
and uh yeah this is this is one of the
questions they have to answer because if
it's an object it can't extend forever
because an object is the opposite it has
shape that means it has a boundary and
there's something outside of it giving
it you know Contour or providing Contour
contrast or whatever you want to call it
and so that's the way you got to present
The Ether you can't say The Ether
extends forever because it's not an
object it's a concept and for that you
now you need to Define it and you cannot
use it as an object you cannot say it
moves it vibrates you can't do anything
with it because it's concept okay that's
the way it works it's called word salad
it's called Uh semantics Bill you're
doing semantics yeah semantics is the
first step of the scientific method it's
150% of science you if you're going to
give a physical interpretation you know
in physics you had better do semantics
okay okay so here we move on and move to
make a little comparison here you have
the infinite medium and again I put a
white um frame around it just so you you
know to chop it off but you have to
think that all those particles that are
moving there they extend forever and
then here you have a finite medium okay
and the issue here is not you know what
are all those dots we don't care about
that we care about the overall shape of
this finite medium and we care about the
contrast what's the black stuff those
are the two things you have to identify
okay so uh here we have we stop the
motion that's the first thing we had to
do okay so we stop the motion there okay
so that you can see it in one shot no
motion and we don't care again about the
particles okay uh as far as we're
concerned this is what we're staring at
okay which is just a ball okay we don't
care what it's made of we don't ask what
is the table made of what is the
elephant made of we don't care about
that we just point and say elephant we
point and say tree we point and say rock
that's way it is here we point and say
ball if that's what you're proposing for
The Ether and of course the thing you're
going to have to worry about is that
Contour what's that black stuff I need
to know what the black stuff is and if
that's ether the yellow the orange stuff
is uh ether no problem then we need to
know what the black stuff is okay and
then you can begin to do your
presentation now we know what the ether
is according to your way of thinking
okay and uh yeah here we have uh uh two
uh examples again with the infinite
particles and and they put them in some
kind of motion they say oh they're
vibrating and in the other one you have
a finite one and they say it's fluid
okay and no problem there uh uh you know
because the first one the one with the
Yellow Frame around it that's supposed
to be infinite and so that's not an
object whether it's moving or not we
don't care because they haven't
presented the object yet if it's
infinite it's not an object and then the
one on the right is also fluid but here
here it's it doesn't have a frame around
it in other words that orange uh reddish
uh thing looks like a carpet uh that
stands alone but then again we have to
know what the white stuff is that gives
Contour that provides a backdrop to that
red uh rectangle okay so no problem in
the in looking at that red um rectangle
and saying That's The Ether no problem
and that it's moving it's it's made out
of a single piece no problem there the
only problem here is that we need to
know what the white stuff is okay you
have to identify the white stuff that
gives Contour to it the other one the
other one's not even an object it's a
concept because it's infinite so it
doesn't qualify as an object you have to
the the again the Yellow Frame is
artificial I put it there because you
know I can't give I can't present an
infinite object for you sorry no such
monster all objects have shape the one
on the right the red one has shape but
we need to know what the white stuff is
and so you do have to tell us you know
what the what the backdrop is okay and
so let's look at some of the conclusions
here okay ether is can't Define The
Ether uh because it's a concept and so
they don't want to Define it as a
concept because they want to use it as
an object that's the problem and they
can't point to The Ether meaning you
know the the shape in front of us uh
Contour or whatever uh why because uh
they say it's infinite usually they they
or they imagine it to be infinite okay
and they don't always state that
sometimes they say it's the same thing
as space sometimes they say The Ether
contained within space like if space
were something different than the ether
and so we have these uh contrasts these
contradictions between all these ethers
that's one problem but yeah we need to
know whether ethers an object or a
concept concept we define object we
point to very simple and if if you point
to it we need to know what the backdrop
is what what serves as a contrast then
uh ether you know they they uh like to
live with all these dualities
contradictions
paradoxes um you know it's uh they want
the medium this thing called ether to be
both a medium an object and a concept so
they use it as both just like the
SpaceTime by the way you know SpaceTime
you know that thing that warps that's
called gravity okay so it's SpaceTime a
physical object well it's an object it's
a concept it's both see and uh what is
light well it's both it's a wave and
it's a particle you know so they have
all these dualities they put them in
there because they want to cover all the
bases they want the best of all worlds
that's why they put them they that's why
they never differentiate between
Concepts and objects okay that's the
problem and uh you have to tell us is if
it's infinite or finite if it's finite
it's an object but if it's infinite it's
not an object it's a con concept okay um
ether a lot of people say it's
unimaginable why because they they want
to put it beyond your reach they don't
want you to criticize their God and they
pray to The Ether and they say oh you're
going to tear my ether apart that means
all my theories go down to drain I'm not
going to allow you to do that so I put
it beyond your reach I don't know what
the ether is I can't draw it because I I
don't know how to draw very good you
know they come up with all these excuses
no no you must you must absolutely must
illustrate your ether if you're going to
use it as an object as a thing as a
medium as an entity or whatever you want
to call it all those words are synonyms
in
physics okay and uh so they do a flu
flow flow flu flu flow flow flu uh
seashell seashells by the seashore uh
how many much wood with a wood chuck
chuck wood Chu wood Chu wood okay I
think I'll recover myself and I'm okay a
flu flow flow flu yeah it always a fluid
that flows and a flowing fluid and yeah
and they also want it to be static so
they have both worlds again some people
say it's stating the other one says no
it's moving and so they haven't figured
out what the ether is yet okay so again
you have to deter determine whether
ether is an object or a concept it's a
object try it then you can move it and
flow and fluid and do do whatever you
want it and if it's a concept uh you
can't use it as an object at all you
just Define it and I don't know what
what use you're going to give it okay uh
yeah so it's unimaginably put beyond
your reach okay ether uh is against the
scientific method the way it's used
today okay the way it's always really
been used because they've always used as
bunch of particles that's what it's
always been infinite particles that's
what ether has always been and they're
always vibrating you know it's not a
Sandbox like static they're always
vibrating okay and some people say well
it's a Sandbox which is what uh Michaels
and Morley essentially assumed that it
was like a static bunch of particles out
there like a Sandbox and light was
moving against the sandbox so I don't
know what they had in the back of their
minds when they did that test would have
been simple for michelon and Morley just
to say look that's the ether and once
you point to The Ether you say now I
know what you're going to test right now
we don't know what they tested we don't
know what they had through in the back
of their minds when they did this their
experiment okay uh so ether is that's an
irrational individual why because you
know uh it's not part of science unless
they can show us what the ether looks
like it's not part of science not part
of physics okay physics requires an
object okay and again science rational
explanations physics rational
explanations of causes and mechanisms
and uh you can't uh use Concepts as
objects okay that's what's
irrational so we have a definition for
what rationality and irrationality is at
least one of the criteria there's a
couple more
okay okay how about us you know us the
threads you know the single
thread do we do the same thing as the
ethers now we do something a little bit
different than all of them mainstream
and ether and electric universes and
flat earthers and all these other people
we're the only people on the planet
Earth that do this okay so just in case
you happen to drop by here that's the
single thread that thread is the one
that's going to turn into everything
it's going to turn into atoms connected
by electromagnetic ropes in in other
words a pair of twined threads of that
same stuff move on to another atom
constructs that atom continues on the
other side as a pair of twined threads
continues to another atom and so on down
the line from one end of the universe to
the other there's a single thread in the
entire universe that's what we're
proposing and the object is a single
thread there you see it I hope uh
everybody can see his shape there now we
put it in motion but obviously we can
stop it and you can still see that
thread and again uh for those who want
to play Devil's Advocate looks something
like this okay I don't need to move this
for it to to be a a thread okay it's a
closed loop thread essentially that's
what we're saying okay you can see it
there it is that's what that's all there
is in the universe according to what we
propose here that's the Assumption okay
and um that thread turns into this okay
it goes from uh this closed
loop uh to twine threads twins around
itself around the entire universe really
okay and uh you can see how the more it
twines eventually it turns into atoms
connected by a pair of twine threads
which we call a rope okay because that's
what it looks like or we call it a rope
only because it looks like a rope like a
one you buy two strand rope you buy at
the hardware store and then from there
you can see all the atoms in the
universe they're all interconnected so
the atoms are made out of the thread so
are the ropes that connect them the pair
of twine threads and all atoms are in
the universe are physically connected
they're interconnected okay so I think
it's a very straightforward you know for
uh those of you who um who want to
ponder this assumption and from there
construct the theories of light and
gravity okay so here we have
um this same F and he goes in there and
he says uh because this you know because
he he he thinks it's all the all of this
is word Wizardry word salad semantics he
doesn't realize that the establishment
is doing that to him and that's the
problem that he's got really with what
they do in the establishment says here
SpaceTime is a mathematical reification
has no material properties yeah tell
them about it they say that uh gravity
is a warpage of SpaceTime SpaceTime is a
bunch of what number lines and they're
bending the number lines and they're
telling you that's gravity and so this F
says well it's a metric in physic a
metric is a numerical value derived from
measurements etc etc SP time is a number
a quantity used in the field in the
field equations of general relativity
not a material which can bend curve or
warp well then why do they say that you
know SpaceTime warpage is
gravity you know in other words they're
saying that the Earth doesn't fly out of
the solar system because there's a
physical object that's bent that's
warped and prevents the Earth from
flying out of the solar system this uh
the Earth or the moon you know they go
around a depression that looks the the
whole mechanism looks like a uh like the
roulette okay and that's what they're
explaining they say look you have this
roulette mechanism you have a depression
and the moon goes around the earth and
the earth goes around the Sun why don't
they fly out because you have um this
depression this wall that prevents the
Earth from flying out and what is that
wall it's SpaceTime and SpaceTime what
is spacetime it's a pair of coordinates
really a pair of number lines couple of
four of them really okay so you have uh
number lines and so the mechanism
they're telling you is physical
mechanism is that there's these number
lines are preventing the Earth from
flying out and then you say Well they're
they're using a euphemism or you know um
a a way of speaking it's it's just a you
know uh a manner of speaking
and and really what they're saying
they're giving you a mechanism so you
can't say it's just a matter of speaking
a euphemism you know or a figure of
speech they're actually telling you in
your face that that's the mechanism that
their mathematics
proposes so he leaves them off the hook
he says well it's okay because they're
just using poetry and we we don't really
believe the
Poetry but that's the mechanism they're
giving you so you better believe the
poetry because that's the mechanism
they're giving you for why the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system so
don't tell me it's just poetry and it's
just euphemisms and uh you know whatever
they're actually telling you and you say
well that's just an analogy an analogy
for what what does it mean what what is
the analogy of warp time for If gravity
is warp time that's what prevents the
Earth from flying out of the solar
system but it turns out time is just a
what a number line or what they call a
coordinate or Dimension fine then
you're talking about a mathematical
concept preventing the physical Earth
from flying out of the solar system and
so on the one hand they say well this is
just a way of speaking we can't put our
equations our numbers into regular
words yeah you can't I know you can't
and that's why why are you even trying
why are you trying to explain to the
common man out there you know that you
know how this universe works it works
through this depression called SpaceTime
when you called her Bluff they say well
that's just a figure of speech and we
don't do that anyways it's not part of
our job we do in our line of work is we
do equations well if you do equations
stay with your equations don't bring
them into physic don't tell me that you
understand how this universe works and
that we have all these depressions in
SpaceTime out there in the in the
universe so it's one or the other either
you do know or you don't know if you
don't know shut your mouth you know
don't don't get into physics don't tell
me that you know how this universe works
and so this guy continues and he says um
no one thinks that curved lines of
isobars drawn on a weather map or the
longitudes and latitudes drawn on a
globe represent anything that is
physically real no those are not real be
because we're not using those longitudes
and latitudes we're not bending them to
produce gravity a physical thing that's
a description of the earth these people
are saying something totally different
they're saying that they're warping the
number lines and that is why you know
the Earth doesn't leave the solar system
so that's a little different and of
course this guy leaves them off the hook
he says it's okay that they use all this
stuff why because he doesn't understand
that that's where the problem is in the
language you know these people are
giving you a physical interpretation for
gravity and they're saying it's warp
time and this this fell just leaves him
off the hook and says well that's okay
you know he does it as well he he you
know again he he doesn't tell you what
the ether is well you know what the
ether is it's sad FL flow flu the flu
flow you know flows fluid that
flows yeah so he's he's in the same boat
they're all in the same boat because
they don't know where space stops and
they say well it's infinite now if it's
infinite it's not an object and if it's
finite you got to tell me what's on the
outside of it and so you can't have it
both ways and yeah when you realize that
space is a
concept St stands for that which doesn't
have shape now we're we're okay because
it's a concept and every object every
atom has this as a backdrop okay the
nothingness of space then you can
understand it as long as you start
talking about Infinities you know which
belong really to math you're never going
to make sense of
it okay and here we have good old
Stephen Hawking and he says what
SpaceTime is he says hope been helpful
to think of for coordinates of an event
as specifying its position in a
four-dimensional space called SpaceTime
so he's saying what what is spacetime a
four-dimensional whatever right and uh
and then he says it's impossible to
imagine a four dimensional space yeah so
on the one hand he doesn't realize he's
saying it's four coordinates it's not
even Dimensions it's coordinates because
that's all they have in mathematics
coordinates and so he's he's trying to
imagine four coordinates out there and
he's not going to imagine them because
uh that's a concept you cannot imagine
you cannot make an image of an
illustration of four coordinates
you know uh perpendicular to each other
okay it's just impossible and so yeah uh
he doesn't realize why he cannot imagine
it so poor Stevie you know he he had no
clue whatsoever you know again just a
mathematician and all these people have
very little understanding of physics
what they know is a lot of equations but
what they don't know anything about is
physics for physics you need ordinary
language ordinary speech uh you know the
everyday language to be able to explain
something not numbers we don't use
numbers in physics you got to explain a
mechanism you can't explain it with
numbers or
equations okay so another fellow brings
up he says you recently suggested that
the fundamental threads making up
everything possess the properties of
invisibility and intangibility yeah
exactly you know that's exactly what
we're proposing we're saying that the
thread right uh in the Rope uh
intangible and invisible in fact uh very
simple if we we take the pencil again
let it go something is pulling from it
like uh we said in the past every atom
here is connected to every atom of the
Earth the closer it gets to Earth the
more the ropes span out that means that
uh acceleration of gravity is just more
and more Fanning out of the ropes that's
all it is a very simple mechanism
kindergarten stuff by the way okay and
so he says um you know he said but how
can they pass through each other again
tangibility is what gets all these
people they're talking about
intangibility how can he pass through
each other I cannot understand that I do
not accept it because every day you know
in every day s we can't pass through
objects and so he's asking how does how
does this work you know he says how
however doesn't your jump Road analogy
that I use uh to explain the mechanism
of magnetism involves swinging threads
around both North and South Poles yeah
either pushing away through clockwise uh
counterclockwise collisions or
attracting through both threads swinging
clockwise and briefly intertwining isn't
that a logical
contradiction okay so uh I have said
this in the past I'm just going to go
briefly to answer this gentleman and so
this is the answer for him uh
tangibility comes when you have many
threads okay in the case of uh the
electron shell all those electron shells
are made out of tons of threads uh which
they probably even have several layers
for all we know but uh even if we have a
single layer what you have is now a
surface for the first time okay and
that's why the atom is um under certain
conditions if you send an an atom
against another a neutron against
another atom uh you have a totally
different situation we're not going to
get into that right today but all I'm
saying is tangibility why an atom cannot
normally go through another atom is
because it has a surface what is the
surface it's the electron shell what is
the electron shell many many many
gazillion ions of threads uh weaving the
surface of that shell and in the case of
magnetism which is the one on the right
uh what you have is a wall of threads
moving around it's a wall it's not just
one thread we're talking about a wall of
threads and now it uh it doesn't even
really push completely what it does is
go through the other uh because it's
going at Great speeds it's swinging
around at Great speeds it goes right
through but it creates a certain
friction that the other uh magnet senses
the the threads of the other magnet
sense and with tons of these moving
around like a Paddle Wheel you know of
of a Riverboat uh what you have tons of
these moving around and that's why they
create that push mechanism because there
what what's actually happening is you
have tons of threads that form walls one
wall right after another as a Paddle
Wheel of a Riverboat and what what it
does is um go through each other but
creates this tenuous friction which uh
only gets stronger and stronger the
closer two objects are together because
now you have more and more walls of
threads going through each other okay so
that's that's why it hits and pushes
each other away one thread can go right
through another and there's a very very
imperceptible friction there perhaps but
when you have walls now there is a more
important friction and if you you have
many walls turning around now you have
more friction more pushing right and the
closer the objects are together the more
threads because you have more atoms
closer together they're swinging around
you have more and more threads the
closer you try to get the two magnets
the more they try to push each other
away the farther away well now the
threads you know again uh can go through
each other without causing uh attraction
or repulsion so that's the notion the
notion is the quantity of threads form
these walls once you have the wall now
you can figure out why they push or why
they attract okay so that's the general
notion of that now the fellow
says are these supposed uh ropes
intangible or are they physical
mechanisms you can't have both well the
first thing is uh they're not mechanism
rope is a mediator a thing an object
okay you shouldn't confuse that with a
verb called mechanism okay mechanism is
what the ropes do okay that's the first
issue so uh he says uh well you can't
have both Well Physical mediator has
nothing to do with tangibility or
visibility a a an object is that which
has shape there you see it at the bottom
physical that which has shape okay so
physical means that it has shape not
that it can be touched or seen okay so
no experiment you know therefore no
experiment meaning eyes or hands right
uh can
determine an object or a thing immed
mediator that is invisible and
intangible okay
so plays no role the tangibility plays
no role in this uh matter at all
whatsoever okay and then we have another
fellow and he says the following talks
about the gut so this is not a grand
unified theory meaning you know the the
Rope can where I put the Rope here uh
rope serves both for light the torsion
along a rope okay between two atoms and
then it also serves uh for Gravity
because all these ropes are connected
like from the pencil every rope from
every atom here is connected to every
rope on the earth and so the same rope
that where you send light from one atom
to another that one also serves for the
gravitational phenomena meaning you know
as the pencil Falls the ropes fan out so
it's so essentially one mediator for two
mechanisms one is gravity and the other
one is light okay so that is the gut the
Gran Unified Theory otherwise known as
toe
uh what is it the uh Theory of
Everything and here here just just to
clarify right um where is it
here uh the difference between the gut
versus the toe just so that people are
aware any model and particle physics
that merges the electromagnetic weak and
strong forces the three interactions
into a single Force at high energies
okay that's what the gut is and for us
it's all the same gut or told that it's
the same thing be The Theory of
Everything why because a theoretical
framework revealing a deeper underlying
reality unifying gravity with the other
three interactions and that's what we're
saying we're saying there are no three
interactions there's only two there's
only push and pull those are the only
things we can imagine the only forces we
can imagine and um and so light is a
push and gravity is a pull and rope can
push and pull that's one thing good
about a rope it can do a if you torque
it it causes some a little pressure at
the end and at the same time it's
pulling on whatever's at the other the
two ends so robes can push and pull
particles can only push okay and that's
why the Rope unifies the gut and so this
fellow says I know he talks about some
other stuff that has no relation to this
I don't know what he thinks the gut is
but he says gut ties all conspiracy
theories together into one so he get
went into politics overarching uh
conspiracy theory that explains how our
minds are controlled and by who or what
and for what purpose so I don't know
what this guy knows about the grand
unified theory to ass soon that the puny
human mind can fully comprehend the
Majesty of God's creation is bordering
on
blasphemy yeah a human mind can
comprehend it we can comprehend if God
came here today and told us how gravity
Works how how light works we would
understand it we are intelligent enough
to understand what God is telling us
especially if it's baby stuff stuff like
gravity you know uh all we had to do was
make visible the invisible ropes and
then we understand gravity we understand
light we understand why the Earth
doesn't fly out of the solar system we
understand why this pencil falls to the
floor and we understand what light is
because uh you know it's a just a rope
conveying a a signal known as a torsion
and so we would understand if God came
down here and explained it to us we'd
say okay I understand what you're saying
now God you know he knows everything he
tells us we we have the intelligence to
understand them there's nothing a human
cannot understand but see they put it
out of your re and say well the father
Universe speaks a different language
than humans and we'll never understand
and all we can do is search and and uh
try to find and never find really right
and that's the same thing he's got in
his mind he's saying it's I leave it up
to God I put it beyond the reach of
everybody nobody can understand what God
created and we have to leave it like
that we have to we have to leave it
without understanding it well that's
okay for him not for intelligent people
okay we see through the glass Darkly and
are not Gods yeah we are the Gods in the
sense we're not we're mortal that's the
only thing we're not gods of and we're
also mortal as a species you know so
we're about to die we're approaching
Extinction so we're not mortal uh we're
mortal both individually and
collectively uh so in that sense we're
not Gods but we're gods in the sense
that we have the intelligence of God God
has no more intelligence than us okay so
sorry God is not more intelligent we are
gods in that sense we are the what is it
the uh caretakers of the Garden of
Eden okay let's move on to the subject
matter today the prime one which was
teleportation and uh so what is
teleportation well it says that you can
move things around you know by remote
control kind of you know it just happens
and it moves from here to there
and they call it teleportation because
it just moves and apparently nobody
knows the cause okay and here we'll
start with this one I don't know if
you've ever seen this but comes from
popey and here's our our first uh proof
evidence of
teleportation and here you have Bluto
and he's going to do some action at a
distance and suddenly you know you have
this wall move upwards and he all goes
through all the Sinbad and his 40
thieves and when poor old popey tries to
get in there well he's upset because he
doesn't know the trick he doesn't know
how it's done and all he had to do is
open sesame okay and then uh the wall
would have opened up but he didn't know
that at the time okay so it took him
some time to understand that okay so now
you know that's uh teleportation and uh
action at a distance and remote control
all that's been around you know at least
since the days of popey believe me okay
but uh here we do a teleportation here
here's in the um in the city of New York
a magician does this okay and here it is
let me show you this this is the
trick and the guy's going to put that
thing over these four people and
suddenly the four people appear
somewhere
else pulls a string they disappear here
and they appear over there okay now is
that for a trick okay so yeah
um this is a magic trick and people say
was that real teleportation was that
quantum teleportation or general
relativity teleportation what no no that
was a magic trick it was a trick they
fooled you okay maybe it was done with
mirrors who knows you know I mean uh mag
magicians don't tell you their secrets
you got to find out for yourself you got
to figure it out of yourself okay so no
problem uh that's a magic trick does ma
does teleportation occur in reality or
only in cartoons and in uh in um you
know under magicians tricks well let's
find out let's go to some uh you know
reliable
sources here's me National Science
Foundation says is teleportation
possible yes in the quantum World uhuh
and says while human teleportations
currently exists only only in science
fiction teleportation is possible now in
the subatomic world of quantum mechanics
Al B not in the way typically depicted
on TV in the quantum World teleportation
involves the transportation of what
information so they're transporting
teleporting what information a concept
they they teleport Concepts that's great
rather than the transportation of matter
okay so what are ma math mathematicians
into they're into concept they always
transfer concept they move Concepts
around they use Mass to attract stars
move them around you know whatever they
deal with
Concepts and teleportation is no not an
exception they're saying teleportation
happens but what we're teleporting are
Concepts okay so keep that in mind we're
not transporting or teleporting matter
what we're doing is transporting
teleporting moving
Concepts okay so here we have one you
might say Bill you just pulled one out
of there you know out of nowhere okay
here's a physicist so-called physicist
mathematical physicist and he's going to
explain teleportation to you okay so uh
I did the uh blah blah blah in the
background but I imitated every word
that he said okay and it's also written
there so try to read as fast as you can
because these uh videos go quite fast
here it goes uh give me a second here
here it goes listen
carefully the good news is that
teleportation is
real bad news is that at the moment we
can only teleport one atom at a time and
the record for teleportation at the
moment involving one atom is teleporting
over a distance of, 1400
kilometers of the Chinese satellite
called
metheus they teleported an atom from the
ground up to the satellite so the actual
atom never moved all you do is take one
atom and measure its exact
properties and in the process of
measuring its properties you actually
mess it up and lose that
information but you can transmit that
state to the
spacecraft and you can recreate an atom
exactly the
same okay so they
don't
um transfer uh objects they don't
transfer the atom what they do they
mimic or they reproduce the properties
of that atom in another atom and this
one is destroyed in the process and the
other one over there now is the new old
M old atom so they claim that's called
teleportation because they transferred
the properties of one atom to another
atom which is now identical to this one
uh I don't know how that can be because
there are two different locations so uh
at least one property is not the same
which is location and I think it's a
very important property here especially
if the atom is At the other side of the
Universe I mean if they say
teleportation occurs instantaneously and
you have one atom on this side of the
universe another one on that side of the
universe and you just transfer the
properties over there and I guess uh now
the monkey over there is dressed in the
same suit as the monkey over here well
is that's the same monkey as this one
because one thing is different about
them and that's location okay so that
property was not trans transferred the
property of location okay okay here's
another fellow and his name is um not
Mike Tyson it's his
brother uh Neil Tyson what does Neil
Tyson say well he says that uh forget
about teleportation teleportation is
easy uh but he hopes one day to have a
wormhole and he can slide through this
onedimensional number line and and be at
the other side instantaneously it's a
teleportation using the uh the Wormhole
as a mechanism okay so listen to the man
here he's gonna we're going to hear from
the horse's mouth here it
goes
teleportation I cannot begin to tell you
how game-changing that would
be what you really want is the power to
open a wormhole anytime any
place
on Star Trek they go into the
Transporters and beam
somewhere if they had Rick's power of
portal you just open a portal step
through and you are where you need to be
you just step through a
wormhole I can't wait the future when we
have
wormholes the day we have wormholes you
won't need
airports
so uh this other fellow was saying that
these people are just talking about
euphemisms figures of
speech what's this fell talking about
what's Neil Tyson talking about he's
saying that you can go through a
wormhole to another Universe
instantaneously you're you know just get
into the black hole uh that's serves as
the uh wall you know the interface and
you enter there you go into the Wormhole
and you arrive at some other place
instantaneously so that we have this
teleportation Through the
Wormhole you know uh are these people
for real they talking for real and if
they're not talking for real why are
they putting this nonsense on TV on uh
you know in in the media to try to
convince people that they know what
they're talking about if it's not real
then what is all this nonsense the other
fellow says you can only transfer you
know uh properties this doll says no I'm
going to be transferred I'm my body is
going to be transferred Through the
Wormhole teleported to another universe
so what is it you know is it just
Concepts or are we transferring objects
like human beings teleporting like you
know Star Trek shows you go into a
teleporter they disintegrate you
disintegrate you here and you appear
integrated somewhere
else so let's let's find out are these
people talking for real or they talking
about you know where do they go to
school Hollywood
University what is this is this science
and yeah this is what they feed the
public and so a lot of people believe
that this is real and so why why are
these people love should they should be
uh uh censored on YouTube for you know
passing false
information okay they censor us for much
less wonder why they don't censor these
people selling garbage to the public
these people are committing crimes
against humanity that's what they're
doing okay so here's another U famous
it's called minute physics some of you
most of you probably heard of it or know
about it and uh they these people say
that if you um if you're transferred
like uh uh Neil Tyson said you transfer
instantaneously somewhere else whether
through a wormhole or just teleport or
whatever inside the room is that other
fellow you or is that another fell
because you know we're transferring all
your properties all your
uh uh feelings your headache uh you know
your pain your your love everything that
you can think of all your Concepts in
your body transferring your Concepts to
this other fellow they have to
disintegrate you because otherwise we'd
be creating another you there'd be two
's to you know clone and so they have to
destroy you and they create you over
there with all your properties whatever
that is right all your feelings whatever
and now over there and the question is
that you the same you that started that
you know where the experiment started
and this here it goes he goes quite fast
so you got to pay attention here he
goes when a transporter dis Manel every
atom in your body and reassembles an
identical arrangement of atoms somewhere
else perhaps a disassembled you actually
dies and to reassemble you is actually a
new being that just thinks it's you and
if they simply hadn't dismantled the
original U then there would now be two
U's in the universe and which is really
you you or the teleported
you are these people kidding me is this
science I mean all this is put out there
as if it were science and this other
fellow says you know they're talking
about euphemisms they're you know
presenting figures of speech they're
doing analogies it's the real thing
these people actually believe all this
stuff and if they don't believe it why
are they presenting it as science I mean
this should not be in a scientific form
this should be and they're writing
papers on this scientific papers you
know in the scientific literature as
they call it I mean this stuff should is
okay for Hollywood I have no problem
they make a movie out of the stuff and
say hey this is fantasy this is science
fiction we love it yeah I love it too
you know go back to the past see your
grandfather all that kind of stuff I
love it but the think that this is real
like these people are presenting it in
science forums writing papers into the
scientific
literature that's something else that's
totally something else especially when
they claim that they know how this
universe works when you challenge them
they say well you you took it too
literally bill yeah physics is literal
it had better be literal if you say
there's a wall blocking the Earth from
flying out of the solar system you mean
exactly that and you can make an analogy
and say well the wall is like the uh
wall of Berlin you know Berlin Wall okay
fine no problem you can say something
like that but you cannot say it's time
you know it's like saying like we were
talking the other day about uh frame
dragging you know the Earth uh drags
time around and What analogy am I going
to use you know I can say that the dog
drags um the uh my clothes around you
know got him with his teeth and drags my
clothes around and we can say it drags
him around like a tugboat drags a a ship
you know because one tugs and the other
one tugs we can all see that we can see
you know the simil the similitude
between the two scenarios but when you
say the dog drags seconds around like
the Earth drags time around you know
what is the analogy what does that
analogy stand for what is that idiocy
especially when it presented in in a
scientific Forum you know so that is
nonsense that is poock the that and so
they don't say well the Earth doesn't
drag time around what they say it it
drags uh frames around it's a frame
dragging mechanism and people say oh
that's so scientific it's over my head
and what they're saying is that the
Earth is dragging time around itself and
so I don't know if you're satisfied with
that well God help
you okay so what's the problem with all
this teleportation and Wormhole uh in
instantaneous transfer Across the
Universe well what's wrong with it is
this you know here we have and I'll just
illustrate it okay we have a magician
and he's going to cut the later in half
in fact there's no magician here it just
shows that the lady is cut in half right
and uh then you
know curtains closed curtains open and
the girl comes out and she's in one
piece and so it's a trick right it's a
trick now I don't recommend you do it at
home with your wife or your girlfriend
you know take the saw and cut her
because might really do some damage
there you need to know how the trick is
done then you can go in there and saw
you know uh the lady in half at home but
you need to know the trick okay and
that's the issue and so here let's look
at um this um this trick this magic
trick goes more or less like the first
one there where they had that levit that
um teleportation you know from one box
to another of all these four people well
this is something similar they're going
to cut the lady in half and watch it so
that you see what uh what we have to
answer what in in terms of teleportation
what what the issues are here it
is
okay we all see it saw the lady cut in
half she put back into one
piece uh we have a description we say
okay this is what happened do we know
why it happened how the trick was done
so when you say teleportation same thing
you say okay it was over here and
suddenly it appeared over there I don't
care if it's an atom I don't care if
it's the properties of the atom a
concept you know we don't care what was
the mechanism that's what we want to
know how was it done how did it happen
and he people say it
happened okay yeah the lady was cut in
half it
happened but don't do it at home because
you don't know how to do it you don't
know the trick like like popey he didn't
know how the trick was done uh how did
Bluto you know Sinbad how did he pull
that that wall up by saying open
sesame so uh this is what we need to
answer and these people are not giving
you the mechanism they're just saying it
it is so but that's because that's their
interpretation based on the particle
model that's why they say well this
particle was over here and suddenly we
saw it over there well did you is that
is that a correct physical
interpretation for
teleportation was the were the
properties of this atom transferred over
there well first we can't transfer
properties so that's not a mechanism you
can't say you transfer properties and if
you transfer the atom from here to there
what was the mechanism how did you do
that instantaneously you know how did
this atom suddenly appear some where
else destroy here and appears here and
and again you got to give me the
mechanism without a mechanism you got
absolutely nothing and that's what we're
missing from mathematical physics okay
um so here we have for example here's a
for the lady cut in half I want to show
you uh what the difference is between a
description and explanation some people
don't understand that here it is the one
on the left that's uh you know the
description that we get from the
mathematics medical establishment the
guy said it happened you know and gives
you an equation and says a is head B is
torso and C is legs right and then 20
Strokes of the saw 10 seconds two pieces
two curtains Clos and open and once uh
it opens again the ladies in one piece
that's a description so far you haven't
told me how it was done physics on the
other hand gives you an explanation of
how it could have been done these are
different theories of how the magician
did the trick in one case you know the
lady is below the level of the saw
underneath the stage for example in
another case it's two girls okay one
with the legs the other one with the
with a head and another one same thing
but you can see they're in different
positions so these are different
theories of how this trick was done and
that's what we're asking you know for
the mathematicians to explain when it
when it comes to Quantum Mechanics
teleportation tell me how the trick was
done don't don't tell me it it is so
because all you're saying with that is
that you're interpreting that under the
particle hypothesis so you say I had an
atom here well did you have an atom
there did you locate it do you know for
sure that that atom was there you know
and if the properties ended up over
there you can't say the properties were
transferred because that's even worse
you can't transfer concept and if you
transfer the particle how did you do it
just tell me how what the mechanism is
okay and that's where we fail with
teleportation as well as all these magic
tricks magic trick fine you know you got
to figure out how the magic trick was
done especially cutting the lady in half
don't do it at home except in the
presence of a relativist he'll tell you
how it's
done okay so here are the conclusions uh
the atam is already there okay in
teleportation that's what they're saying
okay so so it's not like there was a
transfer of atoms they're saying there
was already an atom at the satellite and
another one here on Earth and what
they're going to do is transfer the
proper properties from this one to that
one okay so they're transferring the
properties right and then um they claim
there's no Transportation no
teleportation of matter okay it's the
properties that they're going to
transfer okay and then again Tyson says
hey I'm waiting for the day when we
transfer matter you know like me you
know human being from here to there like
in uh Star Trek and then uh yeah again
we can't teleport Concepts but that's
what they claim that they're trans ing
they're transporting they're teleporting
right they're sending Concepts from here
to there they're saying the properties
are being transferred not the matter
okay and so uh yeah we have a problem
with that and then we have another
problem and it's instantaneous they say
from here to there it happen
instantaneously because if I walk over
there that's not teleportation you know
that's normal walking no no for it to be
magic you know for it to be you know oo
and a well then you have to transfer the
object over there from one location to
another instantaneously with nothing in
between that's teleportation okay and so
um yeah it's an instantaneous transfer
essentially because they're
disintegrating you here like at the
teleporter in uh uh Star Trek they're
disintegrating your body here and
reconstructing your body elsewhere and
hopefully you know as they disintegrate
each atom here that atom is assembled
over here so that atom is being
transferred
instantaneously otherwise this one be
disintegrating at the same time that
this is integrating okay and uh and then
uh you know the question is whether you
can do that through a wormhole Wormhole
is onedimensional number line they call
it a dimension coordinate or something
like that Vector uh they use all these
words meaningless words no it's a number
line and what they're saying and by the
way the Wordle is called the Einstein
Rosen Bridge it's not a bridge at all
but they use these words such as bridge
and people think oh it's a bridge yeah I
can see I understand it's like a tunnel
no no the Wormhole is a number line
that's all it is a one-dimensional
number line and when you go through this
onedimensional number line what are you
going through is this a tunnel
threedimensional tunnel how do you get
any matter through there okay so it's
it's absolute nonsense to begin with but
that's another version of the you know
of this um uh teleportation it's Through
the Wormhole you are here and suddenly
you're in a different Universe through
the Wormhole that's the mechanism and
again there's no mechanism there because
they have no mechanism for how you were
transported through a wormhole from A to
B they have no mechanism they just show
you you know the rabbit going through
the hole that's all they show you and
they you say well what speed am I going
through the hole and it turns out you
appear at the other side instantaneously
so it's like you even beat the speed of
light okay so uh the million dooll
question that's all we're interested in
by what mechanism did the m
mathematicians mathemagicians sorry
transfer Concepts what is the trick
that's what we wish to know and
hopefully one of you fellows will be
able to answer that question for me by
next week